let me try skype first and then i'm
going to try discord let's try skype
first
let's try skype
i don't who does he think he is
[Music]
you better pick up oh discord he'll pick
up on discord then
he's gonna pick up hello
let me ask you a question yeah i stay i
do your show
okay last night we're live by the way i
do your show last night
okay till three in the morning i'm out
hanging out with you right
and then you can't even be bothered to
listen to my show this morning
uh i already slept you can't eat oh you
oh oh
oh you know who didn't oversleep me who
went and did your show
you you're and you're just waking up
this has to be terrible
i sat here and i did your show till
three in the morning and also showed you
some amazing
russian dan videos and you sit here and
you can't even
be here for my show this shows you this
kind of friendships i developed folks
it's
one-way street i go on to hang out with
my friends and they
quote unquote over sleep you weren't
over sleeping
you were probably out there listening to
my enemies the tarot card readers
i know that's what you were doing frozen
no i wasn't i i just woke up you sound
really sleepy by the way this has to be
terrible for you
this has to be terrible i blew my voice
out singing yesterday for you
and you don't even have the [ __ ] you
can't even you know
even you can you can't even lie you can
just get it for one second like hey i'm
here and then gone right back to sleep
and i would have probably left you alone
i know you're off today right
yeah oh okay well look i'm sorry well
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna have
you
no i'm not gonna let you go i stayed up
late for you frozen because you're my
friend and by the way not only did i do
your show
you didn't even invite me to do your
show
which it's always been an open
involvement no no no no no no no i don't
want to hear that it's always been an
open that's what you say to the loser
that you don't invite to a party
i know that line frozen i i've used that
line
i've used that line look it's okay
listen i
i understand you probably want to go to
sleep i'm sure you're laying in bed
wearing your [ __ ]
your ninja turtle pajamas
sure just don't hey don't be snarky
you're being snarky with me and i was i
snarky with you yesterday i wasn't
snarky
i'm not i'm not being sucky he's being
frozen hey chat room frozen's being a
little bit snarky right they they think
they know you're being snarky you're
being a little snarky source rex
that's right if you're a dinosaur you'd
be a snark asaurus rex
okay and you know what i wish you would
be extinct right now
because extinct that snarkiness thank
you
uh do you have a race car bed no is it a
bunk bed
no is it a is it a single bed like when
they give you like
like a like a boot camp no it's a queen
size
whoa hey hold on i don't know where he's
doing [ __ ] money bags frozen over
here ooh mr queen-sized bed
huh this is when you have chicks that
come over
it's for chicks sure that doesn't sound
like you have chicks that come over
frozen
am i bothering you i'm really sorry i
feel bad now i feel bad
no i'm up now i know i know i'm not i
really and honestly i don't really feel
bad
but um don't make i'll have john
apologize if you want
that's that's uh it's a good cough there
is it is it the cough
no you're getting up what are your plans
today what does frozen asian do on his
day off
i'm gonna do a little you know what i
said i've been listening to leda pal
drake so much i'm gonna do her interview
style
hey you [ __ ] loser what do you do on
a day off
well today i was just planning on
sleeping
[Laughter]
i was sleeping and but what else
actually you know i had i actually had
an alarm to wake me up
a little bit early but i don't know what
happened slept right through that bad
boy i know what happened somebody kept
you up last night listening to russian
music videos
and also you forgot to record things on
d-life so you have to upload a five-hour
episode of bit shoot which by the way
whenever i upload stuff to bit shoot in
i meant to ask you this joking aside
i open like two-hour episodes of rotc to
bit you and sometimes they just don't
work
like it'll go through the whole process
and then just the video won't work
really does that happen to you
no it's just been the only thing that it
takes like a whole day
just that is true it does it's when it
does work it's like takes forever and
people like
oh why don't you use pitch shoot i'm
like because [ __ ] it maybe works
sometimes
it's terrible yeah oh god
damn i'll oh when i used to upload it
because i i stopped uploading it because
it was just
way too much to even
like process so i was like what i do was
i before i before work i just put it on
like put it up and then wait for it to
process through by the time i get home
which is like
eight ten hours later yeah it's already
up yeah well for me sometimes it'll work
and sometimes it won't like
what i i'm sorry there's real technical
just real quick last
so what's what type of file type do you
upload it as
uh i think mp4 okay that i've see i've
tried mkvs i've tried that before i've
tried flvs i've tried [ __ ] everything
and i have an issue whatever fine
doesn't really matter uh so yes today
you're off
what are your big plans today i know
asian works at a
an asian family-owned asian restaurant
and canada called walk this way
and um it's a clever name it's very good
it's a good name for a place nah but
what do you do today
uh today i don't know i was just playing
just relaxing and video games
well video games and then i got i
actually have some chores to do probably
like
vacuum the house uh
you uh change water change my
aquariums because i got those you have
aquariums how many aquariums
two what kind of three three huh
what kind of fish uh cichlids i have
no idea what those are are you
supposed to eat those remember that
uh what was that movie that you were
playing the one with some really
small fishbowl and we commented uh oh oh
[ __ ] yeah i don't
know i forgot the movie but i've had so
many bad movies but yeah
but yeah those fish okay well i mean
so you have to do fish bowls and
whatever and then you should play some
cyberpunk and you know
make a baby penis or whatever in the
game
i'm just waiting till the the price gets
lower on that game
i'm sorry you're you're a pc gamer right
yes
okay then just download the crack
version it's already up there
what do you have why do you give me the
crack
version for that yeah just download the
cracked version it's super easy
all right i'll do it i mean i mean
honestly i'm just saying it's it's
[ __ ]
you customize your penis
put some boobs on your on your dude and
just [ __ ] kill it dude
i have it i've been playing on the xbox
and i downloaded for this badass
computer it's just
i was like i'm going to do a game stream
but i'm not going to do it during day
wave or during rotc or doing any
i would do like in my off time because
most people don't really like game
streams for whatever reason
um but i'm gonna do one anyway because
i'm playing it anyway
just do whatever the hell you want yeah
i guess you're right i i guess i could i
why do i care what the [ __ ]
these they're listening to us right now
they're [ __ ] everyone the champs
looking at us right now
hey [ __ ] don't look at me sound like
i'm looking at me
makes you feel awkward but yeah get
wouldn't get
get a stream link if you can oh i
already as a matter of fact it's funny
you mentioned that one of our one of my
fans
uh heard that i wanted one and they had
an extra one and they is the sending one
i should probably have it here tomorrow
oh nice i'm [ __ ] excited for my steam
link
i i didn't know that they discontinued
that i thought they stopped in 2018 they
discontinued the steam link
but apparently it's i mean it's great i
have a buddy another friend who used it
that's pl
use it at his house and it's actually
really good um i'm just gonna
or if you guys want to do like jack box
and stuff yeah the jack box is the [ __ ]
best oh [ __ ] you're gonna do one of
those um
do i which one six
yeah oh i haven't i haven't got seven
yet
oh [ __ ] seven's already out yeah seven's
out
ah i [ __ ] love jack box it's one of
my favorites
um it's more it's more party-esque
uh uh games so get blather round oh
whiplash three a new quiplash hell yeah
uh devil's in the details i don't know
that one the only one i really know is
quiplash three but you better [ __ ]
believe
i will be getting party pack seven like
a
it's a it's like a
uh family kind of thing where you're
like a double family and
you have to collect you're all working
together to collect points
okay devil's in the detail what what is
talking points
public speaking can be intimidating when
talking point makes the fun speakers are
giving
picture slides that they've never seen
before oh that one seems like fun
yeah that's trades all right i like that
what's what's
what's what's the champed up
champed up is uh it's another drawing
game so it's like the t-shirt
t-shirt whatever oh i like those ones
too okay oh these look good i'm gonna
get it for [ __ ] sure i'm gonna get it
love me some jack bucks yes
damian scott says seven was blah it's
more for in-room play
yeah yeah it is yeah i like in room play
though but here's the thing
by the way damian yeah here's the thing
yeah here's the thing damian i have
friends like in real life so this is
fine for me
like i have people that actually you
know they physically see so this might
actually be fun for me
yeah i was playing with damian luna and
some other people on my stream once
and we all found that it was better if
it was all in room
for that oh by the way i'm in your dnd
thing and i'm down to play it it's just
i gotta learn it and stuff and i've just
been really
busy and also lazy about learning how to
play dnd
no worries but i want to do it i just
[ __ ] it seems like work like
i was like oh i want to play d d then
it's like oh here's a manual read this
manual i'm like oh great i have to
[ __ ] read
i don't know reading was going to be
involved what they should have done
i actually uh we should just go find new
videos
yeah i i yeah i mean i figured your
videos would have been better thank you
remember what i said and i and i stick
by this and everybody knows this
reading is for [ __ ] and i i'm not gonna
[ __ ] sit here like a [ __ ] and read
like oh i'm gonna read a book
like look i get made fun of enough for
my reading skills right like i'm not a
great reader and i admit to that like i
don't i don't
i don't shy away from it also that being
said
when it comes to rotc i literally do all
the reading and merch does none of it
but whatever that's not
[ __ ] whatever i'm not bitter about
that at all
i'm not bitter about that at all so me
[ __ ] he should read
what i got to read all the time english
english isn't even my first language
oh see where you've been there no i i
wasn't making you funny you're frozen
jesus how long have you known you're not
frozen i was thinking about this the
other day like [ __ ] like [ __ ] 13
years 14 years
uh yeah something like that maybe 12 uh
something 12 i've got frozen asian
forever
i lost count i'm not an undiagnosed
dyslexic you [ __ ] i'm just not good at
reading
something that's undiagnosed dyslexic i
bet shut up
[ __ ] i met you i've met you nicki
you're an undiagnosed artist so shut up
literally met you irl you autist some
[ __ ] be throwing stones um
bruce you aren't good at reading should
do it more and i don't want to i don't
want to get better at reading why
would i want to you [ __ ] guys why
would i want to get better at reading
now what you guys shouldn't be doing and
i'm not advocating for this
is a systematic extermination
oh oh sorry go ahead let's make a
giant paragraph maybe like i don't know
six
seven maybe even eight uh sentences
don't know that through uh rot no no no
no no
no no no no and you know what people are
do let me tell you something frozen
you know what the [ __ ] people are doing
now which really makes me mad man
they're purposely and i swear to god and
then when i tell say this people go
you're lying you're a bad reader
and i'm a bad reader but now people are
purposefully and they've told me they're
doing it because it's funny
they're sending things misspelled on
purpose
i swear to god this isn't a joke so then
i'm just reading them and i'm like well
then i'm great
but then i stumble because i'm like
that's that's not how you spell that
word
though they're sending things misspelled
on purpose for them that way sound even
stupider than i am and i'm stupid
that's fine i'll i'll eat the i'm a bad
reader
but they're doing it on purpose not a
[ __ ] with me and i think that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] as a matter of fact
if i wasn't white now that would be a
hate crime
i mean i don't think it's a hate crime
no it is a [ __ ] hate crime
because i [ __ ] hate it
maybe hate crime when you start acting
upon it but yeah
yeah no i'm not acting look my my point
is this frozen
these people sometimes and i don't think
they mean to be this way but sometimes
they're just mean to me
and i don't think they want to be mean
to me
you know you sure i i mean
i can't imagine these people seem like
good-hearted people
they seem they seem nice you know the
the the damien scotts and the
ck benzonas and the cool boys and the
grandma's watergate salad what the [ __ ]
is that
um the mustard tigers and i can't forget
the back of the bus
uh the benzo boys under the bus now
yeah [ __ ] beau bar you know
and lonely chef and dance not and
earthworm in from infotainment
i don't know who that is i've never seen
that name yet before it's a lot of weird
names
but my point is this
i forgot what my point was that's my
point oh
okay that's my point is i forgot what my
boy by the way joking aside
i did have a lot of fun yesterday doing
the karaoke stream it was actually a
[ __ ] blast man
i it really really was fun it was really
really really good
um coughing is because of all the
singing we did and all the horrible
it was a pretty bit it was pretty bad
singing it really was
uh but i'll let you look i'm gonna let
you go on with your day i just
i wanted to call you and bother you
that's all i'll be in the chat
yeah oh thanks oh no you know what don't
bother
why even bother being in the chat you
busy you got things to do i really want
you to be supportive
it's my new character mom okay
no why even bother why even try you want
to be in the chair you got better dicks
to do obviously to hang out with your
friends it's fine
no go i'm sure you got to go play your
video games and stuff
why he got into chat
it's my new character jewish mom jewish
jewish
all right frozen later skater good
show yeah yeah yeah bye bye
anyway man there goes frozen asian